salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique aujourd'hui je vous
propose une vidéo d' analyse bilan de la
séquence autour d'eric zemmour les
dernières semaines on va donc parler de
plein de sujets différents d'abord le
climat qu'il ya eu autour de sa
précampagne également de sa vidéo de
candidature de son meeting à lille
pointe également des événements avec les
antifas qui elle autour et puis on
parlera aussi un petit peu du futur et
notamment du parti qui l'a lancé alors
tout d'abord quelques mots sur le climat
qui a depuis le début septembre depuis
qu'eric zemmour est entré en
pré-campagne j'ai été extrêmement
surpris de voir à quel point tout le
milieu journalistique au médiatico
politique était extrêmement crispé il ya
quel point il pouvait déchaîné de la
haine contre contre eric zemmour on a eu
même certains politiques qui ont
clairement dérapé même si ça n'a pas
soulevé l'indignation on a eu jean
christophe lagarde est le pays qui a dit
au temps du rpr eric zemmour se serait
pris une balle de la part de pasqua
on a eu fabien roussel candidat du parti
communiste qui lui a appelé à interdire
de présidentielle les personnes
condamnées pour incitation à la haine
qui a appelé les maires a refusé de
prêter à des salles publiques pour
qu'elles les mots face ses meetings
donc voilà on a retrouvé quelque part le
parti communiste totalitaire de la
grande époque
et puis de façon
plus diffuse on a eu également des
mobilisations à marseille maintenant
pourri son nom son déplacement voire
même à l'étranger jusqu'à londres où
quand il est allé rencontrer les
français de l'étranger il a eu une
intervention annulés dans une
institution londonienne
et puis surtout j'ai été extrêmement
surpris de voir notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux toute la haine qui
cristallisait autour de sa candidature y
compris de la part de gens qui
d'habitude sont des libéraux libertaires
bon teint
qui pour le coup se lâchaient
complètement
on a quand même eu beaucoup de
caricatures ainsi autour de zemmour des
gens qui le comparait à gargamel à
gollum à nosferatu ce genre de choses
ça peut paraître anecdotique surtout que
c'est le fait de gens généralement de
gauche ou du centre et pourtant je
trouve que ce genre de caricatures aux
questions puisque
elles ont toutes le même principe monde
écrit zemmour en prenant en exemple un
personnage qui est ville mauvais qui a
de grandes oreilles et un gros nez
et ces gens donc qui d'habitude ne sont
pas du tout soupçonnable d'antisémitisme
je trouve quelque part retrouve par ces
caricatures dans les vieilles caricature
classique de l'antisémitisme on a avec
la culture chrétienne où la culture
islamique sauf que ces gens qui sont des
libéraux libertaires bontin des des
journalistes
politiquement correct redécouvre
quelques parts par l'extérieur par une
forme de convergence évolutive les
caricatures traditionnel mais par la
culture populaire par des personnages de
films ou de bandes dessinées et donc
j'ai l'impression qu'on a une espèce de
d'antisémitisme spécifique à eric
zemmour dans ces milieux antisémitisme
qui ne dit pas son nom alors ça peut
paraître anecdotique mais je rappelle
quand même que dans la présidentielle de
2017 on avait eu un scandale parce que à
un dessinateur des républicains avait
fait un dessin de d'emmanuel macron
qui avait soi disant décrocher et qui
avait déchaîné les critiques et les
procès en antisémitisme alors que le
descendre le personnage avait pas le nez
crochu il avait une bosse sur le nez
puisque macron à une bosse au sun
est il souvent représenter avec cette
bosse sur la mecque et je trouve
étonnant que tous ceux qui sont capables
de crier à l'antisémitisme pour un
dessin de macron là par contre ne sont
pas capables de défendre examen et je
pense que ça montre la taille nautique
mais je pense que réellement ça montre
la place qu'occupe aujourd'hui eric
zemmour dans le paysage
politico-médiatique
il occupe en fin de compte la place de
l'ennemi du bouc émissaire et de
l'ennemi avec un e majuscule c'est à
dire que cet ennemi qui en temps de
guerre réelle ou symbolique et bien ne
fait plus partie de l'humanité cet
ennemi avec qui on n'est plus obligé de
d'avoir les règles d'usagé et un moral
et éthique habituel et donc et qui on
peut se lâcher d'où pour moi ces espèces
de proto antisémitisme réservé
spécifiquement à zemmour y compris de la
part de gens pourtant d'habitude très
très correct et qui lutte contre
l'antisémitisme
et zemmour après cette place parce que
bien elle était vacant depuis une
dizaine d'années avec notamment le
retrait des politiques plus ou moins de
jean marie le pen cette place de diable
de la république pour reprendre le titre
d'un reportage de serge moati justement
sur jean marie le pen cette place de
diable de la république
et bien été laissé vacant puisque
puisque marine le pen en reprenant les
rênes du front national a quand même
réussi à mettre en oeuvre une certaine
dédiabolisation une sorte de
normalisation ou voir même une
banalisation du front national
et du coup il devenait compliqué pour
toutes cette forme de caste politico
journalistique au médiatique qui qui
porte cette on va dire des les valeurs
officielles de notre système dumas qui
prend ses propres valeurs pour les
seules valeurs audible légitimement dans
la sphère politique et médiatique eh
bien ces gens n'avaient plus de
d'ennemis absolue a dénoncé
et zemmour qui lui ne cherche pas du
tout de dédiabolisation qui assume sa
radicalité a pu enfin réincarner quelque
part voilà ses valeurs de ses analyses
de la droite de la droite que marine le
pen lan assumée par assumant par exemple
les notions d'autres comme celle de
grand remplacement
ou de forme de choc des civilisations il
a pu reprendre ce
cet ami qui avait calé jean marie le pen
auprès de toutes les espèces de
nomenklatura
un journalistique aux politiques
pour respectivement aujourd'hui tout est
légitime pour faire taire et moore où
ils crachent allègrement à la gueule on
a même des j'ai vu pas mal même de
journalistes qui sont d'habitude très
politiquement correct sur twitter se
lâcher allègrement
et à travers ses mots en fin de compte
ce qu'on veut faire taire aujourd'hui ce
que ces gens veulent faire taire c'est
le ressenti de toute une partie des
français y correspondent pas à leur doxa
officielle globalement libéral
libertaire adeptes de la mondialisation
heureuse
et du vivre ensemble et pourtant ces
derniers jours justement est sorti un
sondage fait par l'ifop il me semble
pour le journal de la licra
qui qui montrait qui testait justement
des affirmations faites par eric zemmour
auprès de la population les petits
sondages qui montraient qu'une partie
significative et souvent majoritaire de
la population adhérait au constat d'eric
zemmour alors ça veut pas dire adhérer à
sa personne et à ses solutions mais qui
quand même adhéré aux constats sur
l'immigration sur l'insécurité sur 1
un délitement culturel ou même sur les
racines chrétiennes par exemple de
l'europe sondage également surprenant
parce que il montrait qu'une partie
significative des sympathisants de
gauche voilà était d'accord aussi avec
ces constats d'eric zemmour et on avait
souvent 30 à 40% des électeurs de gauche
qui validait le constat par exemple sur
la nature l'origine chrétienne et
blanche de la france il y avait je crois
40% des électeurs de gauche qui étaient
d'accord
parce qu'il montre au passage la
déconnexion totale entre les milieux
militants et les bases électorales
et du coup quelque part ce qu'on essaie
de faire l'adversaire c'est pas
seulement zemmour c'est tout le ressenti
d'une partie du pays
et donc non manifestement toutes ses
sphères qui dirigeante et influente
aujourd'hui ne veulent pas entendre
parler
il le cas on a fini par arriver à la
déclaration officielle de candidature
d'eric zemmour
une vidéo d'une dizaine de minutes sur
youtube vidéos qui elle-même a été en
partie censurée puisque interdite
aux moins de 18 ans
puisque youtube fait donc sa propre loi
et estimé qu'il y avait des contenus
choquants et violent et donc cette vidéo
voilà qui permet à eric zemmour de
s'affirmer enfin le candidat après
plusieurs mois de
deux fosses ambiguïté
du coup je me donne un avis personnel eh
bien j'ai trouvé cette vidéo
intéressante clairement je les trouvais
partie de cette vidéo une grande partie
de sa vie on m'a parlé toute la première
partie en fête ou ou zemmour nous décrit
voilà ces français qui se sentent plus
chez eux dans leur propre pays sentent
étrangers quand il voit dans une
garantie au moins
dans un centre-ville ça très clairement
c'est cette une partie qui m'a
massivement parlé et je pense que ça
parle à beaucoup de gens et si un jour
un des sociologues vraiment posé la
question de pourquoi beaucoup de gens
commencent à accéder à l'expression
grand remplacement
parce qu'ils éprouvent ce genre de
sentiments décrit dans cette première
vidéo partie de la vidéo d'eric zemmour
parce qu'ils sont bêtes et méchants mais
parce qu'il ya un an ils ont un
sentiment de dépossession de l'endroit
où ils vivent ils ont grandi et où l'on
leur a pris à la base qu'ils étaient
légitimes
pour le reste il ya une seconde partie
de cette vidéo qui était plus axée
autour de la grande de la france avec un
grand f majuscule c'est à dire et les
grands personnages les figures
historiques scientifiques littéraires
leur parti qui personnellement m'a un
peu moins par les
parties plus natio entre guillemets kim
a moins parlé parce que en fin de compte
j'aurais aimé qu'ils de faire le de cet
art historique mais qui ne parle pas que
des grandes figures parce que je le
trouve qu'un grand grand absent dans
cette vidéo dans cette partie historique
qui est le petit peuple c'est à dire
ceux qui depuis des siècles avant même
l'avènement de la république
cultiver cette terre longue date y
compris physiquement qu'ils ont
construit les cathédrales les châteaux
les villes
et qui se sont battus pour pour leur
territoire pour leur terroir alors
zemmour on parle un petit peu il évoque
les poilus de 14 mai mais c'est à peu
près tout ce qui règle ce petit peuple
il parle aussi de vous est égal roche
mais ce sont des des figures littéraires
voilà j'aurais aimé qu'il y ait un petit
peu plus de
d'allusions y compris historique à au
petit peuple
sinon personnellement j'ai trouvé cette
vidéo extrêmement intéressante qui dit
en fin de compte ce qu'une partie des
gens ressentent
et qui portent clairement à mon avis un
discours et les la voix de personnes
qu'on n'entend plus trop et compris ce
n'est plus porté par le front national
il se refuse à sortir
des thématiques qui ont été ressenties %
républicaine c'est à dire du citoyen
avec un c majuscule
celui qui n'a pas d'origine qui n'a pas
de culture etc et donc marine le pen
s'empêche de parler justement de ce
sentiment de dépossession en grande
partie
ensuite donc cette annonce de
candidature a débouché sur un grand
meeting à la fois de clôture de la
précampagne qui était forme de promotion
de son dernier livre et deux meetings
justement deux premiers meetings de
campagne
meeting qui devait donc avoir lieu au
zénith et qui pour cause de manif anti
fasciste en partie est apparemment de
nombre de personnes voulant y assister a
été déplacée à quelques kilomètres à
villepinte dans une enceinte plus grande
le mot sur justement la mobilisation
anti phare puisqu'ils ont ils donc un
appel d'une soixantaine d'organisations
de gauche de la gauche de la gauche à
faire taire ces bourrins
et je vous intéressantes parmi ces 60
organisations on retrouve plusieurs
parties qui eux mêmes ont des candidats
à la présidentielle on a le npa on a le
parti communiste et le parti de gauche
également le parti de gauche qui est et
c'est jean luc mélenchon
donc tous partis qui veulent bien
utiliser la présidentielle comme tribune
mais veulent choisir qui a droit de
s'exprimer aux mains
allemand on a des
signatures un peu curieuse comme par
exemple de plusieurs comités de défense
des libertés et des droits de l'homme en
tunisie
donc des gens qui manifestement sont
pour la liberté d'expression en tunisie
mais ce n'est pas en france est un petit
peu incompréhensible puisque les
tunisiens à gauche tunisienne n'est
quelques années a quand même eu affaire
aux islamistes d'être à savoir d'où
vient le péril antidémocratique enfin
ils ont même eu chokri belaid
d'inquiéter le jean luc mélenchon
tunisien qui a quant à elle été
assassinée par des terroristes
islamistes donc ces gens là devraient
savoir d'où vient le danger
apparemment non graves également choses
assez significatif de notre époque il y
avait parmi les signataires des comités
de sans papiers et donc des gens qui ne
sont pas français qui ne sont même pas
légalement sur notre territoire et qui
pourtant déjà veulent nous dire qui a le
droit de parler ou non donc des gens
manifestement délicieux dont on est très
pressés qu'ils aient des papiers voire
même qu'il soit naturalisés pour pouvoir
prendre part au corps civique et est
votée a vraiment des gens qui ont les
autres d'être des amours
donc il ya eu en tout cas ce
rassemblement qui a été fait pas très
loin du zénith qui a été maintenue mais
certains anti farah des courbes comme on
l'a vu un petit peu à la télé on peut
faire un deuxième rassemblement beaucoup
plus près d'eux
de la salle de villepinte avec une
quarantaine d'arrestations des gens que
l'été cocktails molotov et des
bouteilles d'acide donc des gens qui
voient là ont pris au pied de la lettre
appelle à vouloir faire taire eric
zemmour
alors choses intéressantes après
justement c'est rassemblement
rassemblements qui ont été ridicules le
rassemblement officiel du coup pas loin
du zénith a regroupé quelques centaines
de personnes ce qui voilà ce qu'il veut
dire quelques dizaines de personnes par
organisations signataires
totalement ridicule mais du coup sur les
réseaux sociaux notamment après on a pu
voir qu'il y avait des tensions entre
les entrées différents groupes anti
phare c'est à dire que les radicaux donc
notamment l'action anti fasciste
paris-banlieue a appelé donc à
villepinte
il a reproché au plus y est entre
guillemets donc notamment la jeune garde
qui notre organisation anti fasciste et
est initiatrice de la pelle de ne pas
avoir déplacé l'appel parce que voilà du
coup il y aurait pu avoir pire milliers
de personnes pour vraiment faire taire
physiquement eric zemmour
donc il est possible que c'est contre
rassemblements qui ont un petit peu un
petit peu fait flop et bien créé des
tensions
dans les mains dans les temps à venir
le mouvement antifa entre les tièdes et
les plus radicaux
pour ce qui est du meeting de villepinte
en lui-même
yad ailleurs été perturbées l'intérieur
on l'a vu à plusieurs reprises
notamment par sos racisme qui s'étonne
de se prendre des claques alors que je
pense que toute personne allant dans un
meeting et opposés politiquement pour
faire des problèmes que ça prend
toujours une claque je pense que des
militants d'extrême droite qui irait
dans un meeting de mélenchon pour
proclamer l'existence du grand
remplacement d'andré des tartes aussi
bref donc ce meeting de villepinte en
lui-même maintenant
alors meeting qui a duré trois heures
qui était au début annoncé plus tôt
autour de deux heures parce que un
commentateur disait une heure
d'intervenants puis une heure avec eric
zemmour
alors du coup qui a duré trois heures
donc une première heure et demie qui a
été consacrée à un nombre impressionnant
d'intervenants donc globalement on
pourrait dire tous les alliés et tous
les rallyes et azemmour donc que ce soit
les partis des individus vous avez jean
frédéric poisson pourri a donc l'ancien
parti chrétien démocrate vous savez on
peut le marie coûteaux vous avez eue
les gens de sens comme un mouvement
conservateur et des proches d'eric
zemmour qui portait sa candidature
alors honnêtement trois heures de
meeting et personnellement j'ai regardé
ça sur internet h allée cliniquement
j'ai trouvé ça un petit peu long quand
même
très honnêtement enfin la première heure
constitué de plans d'intervention de
gens on connaît pas en plus j'ai trouvé
ça un petit peu un petit peu donc je
pense qu'il aurait fallu qu'on danse et
ça a une heure
réduire le nombre d'intervenants pour
permettre enfin de compte que les
intervenants qui va vraiment
on aurait parlé soit un peu plus
identifiable là je vous avoue que avoir
quasiment une dizaine d'internats
personnes qui ont parlé je suis
incapable de aujourd'hui d'identifier
ceux qui n'étaient pas identifiables
avant le meeting
donc à mon avis il aurait fallu qui est
quand même moins d'intervenants pour
donner un petit peu plus de porter à
ceux qui justement s'exprime et pour
commencer à le faire émerger en fin de
compte dans la sphère les maurienne pour
qu'ils puissent ensuite servir par
exemple d'orateur nationaux dans les
différents rassemblements là où par
exemple
zemmour peut pas aller lui-même parce
que dans une campagne présidentielle on
peut pas couvrir l'ensemble du
territoire
coup ça fait beaucoup de monde dont on
se souviendra pas forcément alors c'est
un petit peu nécessaire parce que c'est
un premier meeting qu'il fallait
remercier tout le monde et donc tous les
alliés et les ralliés devait y avoir un
peu leur tribune en guise de
remerciements mais bon faut respirer
quand même que les prochains meetings ne
seront pas comme ça il ya des premières
parties il faudra réduire largement à
mon avis le nombre d'intervenants pour
les rendre
ne serait ce que pour eux-mêmes quoi
pour les rendre plus audible
on a eu une heure et demi donc d'eric
zemmour de 7h30 à 19h alors au début
honnêtement j'ai un petit peu craint sur
la première demi heure puisque cette
première demi heure a été consacrée à
une forme de management et de
communication vis-à-vis des
sympathisants et des militants ou eric
zemmour s'est posée là on adversaires
des médias
glorifier les gens qui l'ont moins
qu'ils ont rallié ses militants de
terrain
c'est grâce à vous que je suis là ce
genre de choses et ça a duré comme un
petit peu une demi heure ce
manager rial j'ai trouvé d'abord pas
très à l'aise
pour l'instant sur ce genre de choses et
ça a été quand même donneur ce genre de
choses je trouve qu'il serait peut-être
alors
du coup j'ai un petit
hayati tout le meeting est comme ça ça
risque d'être un petit peu un peu
compromis
passé à côté de son meeting et
heureusement partir de 18 heures quand
il a commencé
à dérouler un peu ses propositions à
faire le programme et à expliciter les
choses c'est à dire à faire ce qu'ils
avaient fait dans un petit peu dans la
vidéo de 10 minutes mais en beaucoup
plus longs pour donner du contenu
bien là par contre là j'ai effectivement
j'ai retrouvé un petit peu le zemmour
qui avait dans cette vidéo qui est un
souffle quand même voilà
forme de
d'exaltation de mon sens qu'il est plus
à l'aise qu'il est plus convaincant qui
plus convaincu que dans l'exercice
purement politicien de communication
donc du coup ça là j'ai été rassuré à
partir de 18h en disant bon d'accord là
c'est bon il ya là il retrouve son
terrain il n'ya ses marques
donc en fait mon toit pendant ce meeting
il a également annoncé également la
création de son propre parti reconquête
alors pour moi la structuration de ce
parti est extrêmement importante pour
eric zemmour parce que aujourd'hui
derrière lui il n'y a que des individus
et des parties extérieures il ya que
grosso modo le parti chrétien-démocrate
via qui est structuré nationalement et
qui est capable et bien de porter parole
d'eric zemmour sur le terrain
et donc extrêmement important pour lui
d'avoir sa propre force ne pas dépendre
d'allier à l'extérieur qui peuvent un
moment faire des revirements d'alliance
ou lui imposer des éléments
programmatiques en raison du rapport des
forces
partir en reconquête
aujourd'hui on sait qu'il ya à peine une
semaine d'existence mais revendique une
quarantaine de milliers de personnes
on n'en connaît pas encore la
structuration et on abîme falloir qu'il
fasse assez vite grosso modo ils ont
deux mois avant le début de la campagne
présidentielle pour que ce parti ne soit
pas juste
un rassemblement d'individus mai soit
une force qui puisse réellement porter
la parole de zemmour sur le terrain
et du coup est bien également ce parti
est important puisque c'est ça qui
permet aussi de faire remonter à partir
de la base eh bien les les échos du
terrain vers le candidat
parce que une élection le candidat fait
certes des propositions et par le peuple
mais il faut aussi qu'il y ait des
éléments qui permet de faire remonter et
bien la façon de thé ressenti parmi les
électeurs telle ou telle proposition tel
ou tel dérapage entre guillemets
parce que sinon la seule échos de la
population et de l'électorat qui peut
avoir est à travers les médias et
surtout à la médiane étant pas très fans
d'eric zemmour ils vont fatalement
donner un écho négatif à chaque
situation donc il faut que l'examen
puissent avoir un baromètre beaucoup
plus proche du terrain et normalement
c'est le rôle d'un parti qui
de faire ce genre de choses et pour cela
il faut soit structuré que les
collectifs locaux départementaux soit
suffisamment bien le coordonnées pour
que l'information et le matériel
militant mais circulent dans les deux
sens
pour l'instant je peux pas vous en dire
plus sur la question que je ne sais pas
on peut pas encore trouvé les statuts et
les modes de fonctionnement ni même là
il me semble l'organigramme du parti
reconquête sur internet
helmand une dernière remarque
qui allié alors un petit peu comme le
premier point de cette vidéo qui est lié
au climat qu'il ya aujourd'hui au tour
d'eric zemmour à vrai dire je suis
extrêmement inquiet de l'ambiance
générale
et notamment depuis le meeting de
villepinte où on a vu que la gauche
c'était vraiment déterminé par la gauche
de la gauche plus tôt
tu es réellement déterminés à faire
taire zemmour et compris physiquement
entre les manifs et meeting qui a été
perturbé à plusieurs reprises c'est
quand même pas très bon signe moi
de mémoire je n'arrive pas à me rappeler
de l'élection présidentielle qui est
était aussi tendue comme ça même même à
l'époque où il y avait jean marie le pen
et les antifas en face
mais quand même accor encore à 4-5 mois
de présentiel et déjà je trouve ça je me
sens inquiétant honnêtement qu'est ce
que ça va donner à partir de février
mars quand tous les militants vont se
retrouver quel que soit leur parti au
même endroit pour coller les affiches et
sur les marchés pour distribuer les
tracts vu la situation les tensions qui
a déjà aujourd'hui les coeurs les
antifas la gauche de la gauche enfin
honnêtement ça là on risque de
des épisodes de violence et on va avoir
une campagne qui va être émaillée
d'incidents alors déjà certainement sur
les meetings mais aussi partout
localement sur le terrain avec des gens
qui vont finir par en venir aux mains
les antifas la gauche de la gauche
s'amusait à faire par tout ce qu'ils ont
fait avec des mots ils vont dégager et
que leur d'afficher des gens qui ce
tribut le tracteur et eric zemmour et
ferrari ça va en venir aux mains
d'autres
honnêtement je ne comprends pas
qu'aujourd'hui notamment le ministère de
l'intérieur qui est aussi chargé de la
bonne tenue des élections
n'a tapé du poing sur la table pourquoi
ils ont pas commencé déjà déjà la
question des organisations anti fasciste
elle même notamment la jeune garde et ce
genre de choses on sait très bien que
dès qu'il ya des manies face à l'extrême
droite ça dérape pourquoi ces
organisations ne sont pas aujourd'hui
dissoute génération identitaires ont été
dissous pour moins que ça
jamais eu de violence physique avec
génération identitaire et pourquoi le
ministère de l'intérieur n'a pas
convoqué une partie des organes les plus
importantes qui ont appelé faire taire
eric zemmour pour leur expliquer qu'à un
moment on va finir par l'avoir entraves
à la liberté d'expression et donc qu'ils
vont finir par se prendre des procès
parce que là honnêtement moi je sur ce
côté des tensions et des violences j'ai
l'impression que ça augure quand même
extrêmement mal pour la période février
mars avril
honnêtement si tout le monde s'amusait à
faire comme le fait l'extrême gauche
faire taire ses ennemis politiques enfin
ce serait le chaos total imaginer à
l'extrême gauche perturber les meeting
d'extrême droite extrême droite ou
d'extrême gauche et le centre lui à
perturber les meetings de gauche et de
droite
résultat plus personne ne peut
s'exprimer et la démocratie prend l'eau
et en quelques mois enfin tout le monde
arrive à la conclusion que comme ne peut
plus s'exprimer démocratiquement il faut
passer par la violence et ont en
quelques mois ont basculé en véritable
guerre civile quoi
du coup je comprend réellement pas
aujourd'hui ni ce terreau l'intérieur ne
prennent pas de décisions pour pour
calmer le jeu a notamment du côté des
antilles fin
et le parlement d'ici là si elle
aimerait arriver en un seul morceau
jusqu'au au premier tour
lorsque honnêtement vu comment déjà ses
premiers meetings de là on peut le
craindre craindre le pire
en tout cas voilà pour mes différentes
remarques sur sur toute cette séquence
autour d'eric zemmour
j'espère que
c'est toutes ces remarques nous aurons
intéressés devront type éclairé alors
également cette vidéo est tournée
vendredi donc le suite à l'émission
elysées 2022 jeudi soir d'habitude je ne
regarde plus et vidéos depuis c'est ce
genre d'émission depuis longtemps
ils sont en fin de compte et à tout le
monde passe son temps à la parole les
journalistes jouent les procureurs
politique du coup j'ai quand même
regardé celle d'hier avec eric zemmour
et le bois c'est exactement ça c'est un
procès politique à tout le monde se
coupent la parole léa salamé c'est
prendre pour un procureur donc j'ai pas
grand chose à te dire sur cette émission
très honnêtement je ne vais pas en
regarder
pendant la présidentielle c'est clair
je sais pas vous mais moi je sature de
ce genre d'émission les gens sont plus
foutu de débattre en laissant l'autre
finir sa phrase bref en tout cas si
cette vidéo vous intéressé n'hésitez pas
à partager et vous abonner à la chaîne
est sûre ça je vous dis à la prochaine